there's a spot in London called eel
pumper I'll give that a shot - it's
incredible the telling spot we went last
year after our game that we did between
the Jaguars and the Eagles last year so
we made the reservation again nice and
so we went out for for a nice time meal
Irv was there Michael Irvin and the
whole gang was there and Michael had his
iPad up watching the Jets and the
Cowboys or it was beginning to lose some
power so Kurt put it on his phone okay
I was following along following fantasy
and all that stuff all of the same there
was tons of games all at the same time I
was following along and the app that I
had was a play before what Michael and
Kurt so when the Cowboys went for it on
fourth and short deep in the Jets n okay
right before half and didn't make it I
knew they weren't gonna make it before
Irv saw okay so herve saw and got so
upset he base he said at that point in
time to the whole table that included
Gail Steve marriage his wife Gail my
buddy aforementioned Susie's friends
Debra and her husband Tom and yes he
excused himself to say he needed to
watch the rest of this game in solitude
because of what was about to happen is
is Irv on the phone line right now
reserved on the phone line right now is
this an accurate portrayal so far Irv
here's something you don't know here's
something you don't know on breaking
news to you here okay you were getting
ready to go and at that point in time as
you were letting everybody know that you
needed to be by yourself because you
would not be sociable enough to have a
meal right I saw my phone that darn 'old
connected with Robbie Anderson on this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
he's gonna go the distance
[Applause]
Anderson 92 yards oh yeah my prick my
trolling of Ava's productionvalue now so
um I said I said to Kurt I'm like Kurt
watch this
Irv stick around one more play one more
play just to watch what we did rich
remember came on at 9:25 London [ __ ] yep
925 so I first came in like listen guys
I'm watching myself and we were watching
the other games on Kurt iPad that's
right we were waiting on the cowboy game
to come on and put back on the iPad so
we have the power right and then it
cooked they came back on and we weren't
app lady hi and I would say I gotta go I
gotta go
you know when they got stopped out but I
gotta get out of it I look at my he goes
90 oh man we saw you watching on
something where then I thought it this
must've shot something somebody my how
did you see our theater watching on the
iPhone oh no I tweeted something out I
too did something matter like as soon as
you left as you're heading out into that
London Fog that night
oh yeah I I tweeted out let me see if I
can find this on the spot here I tweeted
out just to be accurate that here it is
here here goes not much better than
watching your team stop Zeke and DAC in
short yardage only to have Robbie
Anderson go 92 for a score right after
all with Michael Irvin watching with you
and then I had the Leo DiCaprio
champagne glass raised Jeff from from
the Great Gatsby which is one of my new
favorites Mike and then I tweeted out to
you after the wit Jets win the me Jeff
smiling at the camera from gameday
morning a couple of weeks ago did you
see that one and well I don't think
these guys understand you can't think
you're good when you are going to be a
measuring stick against four teams right
and all of these guys have been going on
radio shows talking about you know the
Jets are exactly what the Cowboys need
whenever something's l-l is only you
take two yes and call them in the
morning that's what the doctors tell you
well I guess they must have heard some
of that and said we're going to make
sure that we're not the cure but we are
the sickness and that's exactly what
they did Michael Irvin here on the Rich
Eisen show okay so now that you gave the
backhanded compliment of the Jets being
one of those teams that just rises up to
beat Goliath that is now three and three
Michael
what what what ails the Dallas Cowboy
what what gives was it just playing
competition that was if you will beneath
them and crushing them in the first
three weeks have they figured have the
opponents that they faced last three
weeks figured anything out do you think
that was that was right now that they've
lost these three games and they've lost
them three different ways it's one thing
to lose the game one way is it in fact
the back game with that same issue or
that same thickness
or they're saying
this that we call disease the thing
disease but when you have a new disease
robbing your body it's all more secure
and they lost these games three
different ways and and and and that
worries me
now with the injury with the injuries
these injuries are in some very key
spots court mark Amari Cooper being hurt
and then both tackles you saw what they
just be rich they ran a fair front they
put somebody over the center and both
guards and being shot because I was
looking at film they then except Jamal
Jamal in the arm in a gap they were
isolating those two tacos when they
doing that their front they're making
sure that they're going in the center of
cover and they get to isolate the
tackles and then they start the ball
still up there middle and it had no
answer for it that's what I'm concerned
about right there that every team is
going to see that and they'll try to
pull that off for the Dallas Cowboys
yeah I got to be honest of the Irv you
know I mean you mentioned all the
injuries they're just a different team
without tyrants Smith would you agree
with that that goes back to when
obviously when Zeke was suspended if you
remember Smith was out that day in
Atlanta and then it was a total
turnstile behind dak I'm wondering if
this team if that's the answer is it
just as simple as people getting
healthier to write about these a
difference maker and I always told
people you know like like his great as
Larry Allen he is and everything and
everything was different without Eric
Williams he set the tone he kept
everybody accountable on that offensive
line yeah without him it makes it it's a
different game and and I'm worried about
whether these giving in this week I mean
we always talk about a person in and
it's too early to say must win not in
this case this is this is a crucial
crucial game against the Philadelphia
Eagles and it can hurt you in a big way
but if you know
yep because you win this game you're
right back in first place where you want
to be right and the the Eagles are the
only competition they have in this
division with the Giants and the
Redskins being in the state that they're
in so that that's why this game is so
huge and you don't want Philly taking
one in Dallas as well certainly on
Sunday Night Football and certainly with
everything that's going on in the
griddle there in Dallas do you think
even though Jerry has been so strong and
professing it's not the case and same
thing with Steven that that this is a
big moment potentially even dangerous
one for Jason Garrett Michael this has
to be a horrific game just totally
horrific for anything that happened on
that front on existing the air in front
because even after you come out of this
game there's still one game behind first
place if you come out on the moving-in
just doing one game behind first place
so disruption into all of it when you
play put out so much money and run this
season and still have a chance
I just don't think Theory would do that
now if this is a 52-degree game then all
of that may change all of that may
change and it may just be a different
situation where things have to get
disrupted and something else has to
happen and then do you think that Kellen
Moore's offense has been figured out do
you think that's the case and I put that
war on the dog being on the team you
know just a jump that they will get on
it because the line and they dominated
that offensive line and then to come
back and okay you go against Green Bay
and and now you're not even able to move
the ball against Green Bay I mean the
Green Bay
just anything you got any rocks on the
other side so I am worried I am worried
not that maybe they still it filled out
figure it out telling Moore's on often
to figure out how he
all the place that they've had a few
situations in there that I've gone
poorly for them and women - II was just
a little part of it all right I know you
have talent
we know that talent people you know how
to handle the position of expectation
you know it's one thing when you're
trying to climb a mountain and get to a
place it's another thing when you have
to stand on the mountain and try I'm not
everybody down there climbing it and I
don't think the travelers have that
mentality yet and they need to get that
mentality cause everybody's going to
look at them at least they weren't
looking at them early on yeah you don't
think the same look that that is a huge
game they they looked and that was a
huge game for them that's what a lot of
fans cable fans in the New Orleans area
it just that was a only Cowboy fans
which I'm sorry to tell you know a lot
of tribal affairs I know I don't they
happen match the hunger in the intensity
of these teams and they are not prepared
to do that in a or not doing that so in
terms of the other story of the weekend
that certainly got even hotter on Monday
Night Football
I've got Mike Pereira joining me in our
number three former head of NFL refs the
the four calls one that was an on call
in a pass interference
the other ones that were kind of blown
Jerry Jones actually on his radio show
was asked about I want to play that for
you Michael go for it any time you try
to create complete consistency and
complete accuracy just call it right
you've missed the point of interpreting
we've got hands to the face well but we
also call ants to the neck so what are
you trying to accomplish so I mean he's
he's kind of sounding like a fan here
but he's in a very important one when it
comes to officiating what do you think's
going on here Mike Rick I don't know I
really don't know I I'm no ref and I've
always respected
Jonathan these guys have to do but when
I watched that game last night and I
watched every bit of that game when I
thought the first time I was like oh his
hands not on his face um office'll on me
he can't be here but like he was being
driven back like if he was being driven
back yeah you know I know it may be
that's like the new flossing or somebody
call me back in fact but it works it was
full-time at neither time did he have a
hand to a facemask probably incredibly
just just can delete or what only that
works those guys are putting in trying
to win that game to lose that game you
lose collagen and otherwise you answer a
lot of things but in that locker room
they're saying we lost that game are
those two calls if I was in the locker
room I would be saying the same thing
and that is that's just crazy when you
think about it if something has to be
done about that one cannot make those
kinds of mistakes and then make them
back to back and cause games like that
well I am again we're gonna mic prayer
on an hour number three cuz it sounds
like Jerry is alluding to some style
that the the officiating Department is
attempting to to put into place for a
consistency and accuracy that he
believes is clearly not working out but
that'll be later on
hey're before I let you go I mentioned
at the top of the show that Bruce Arians
has a coach on his staff specifically to
let him know when the challenge and
exactly how to challenge with what words
right and that's not work and that's not
working out and he believes that he
thinks that there along with other
coaches that there has been some sort of
change midseason on the way these pass
interference calls have been reviewed
wait wait
I know he thinks he knows if you talk to
the people that are in the locker room
and bring them for me
to the desk or to the air you see what I
mean so you hire a real there have been
in the room go and get information from
the people that are in the room and
bring it to him I don't know why
everybody doesn't have it it's not
working
so I lie down I did it cuz so he's
getting the information from the room
that what they are saying so that's why
he knows is shaming all the time and
they don't have any consistency on
what's going on
that's what exactly why he made those
statements and that's the case that's a
shame before I let you go Michael Irvin
I hope again I had my fun with you with
the Jets beating the Cowboys it was kind
of tame in terms of a New Yorker
delivering some sort of trolling in the
Cowboys direction certainly certainly in
comparison to my guests that I'm having
on Thursdays program is there anything
you want me to play for Steven a Smith
when he joins the show on Thursday
Michael right now
now that the Cowboys lost three in a row
you know he's he's number one on the
cowboy hate this he's really good with
everybody there and talk not that he
understands the specialty of going on
your area okay my thank you
I'm sure me understand that but he wants
to get all of it out and mess with those
Cowboys in and you know Stephen a is my
boy man what I want you to tell him just
tell him happy birthday
you know his birthday is not not how I
know and and and the gift that he
received was he said from the Cowboys
against the Jets so that that's all
you're gonna die you're gonna take very
army it's a very high road Michael I'm
very impressed I bet that's all I got to
say - okay so right now risk that's all
like here everybody is quiet it's just
quiet the weather is not right in Dallas
nothing is like the air doesn't even
breathe correctly anymore right here I
came all the way back to London to
breathe this bad air it's just going bad
right now and I tell you it
this is a horrible game Sunday oh my god
things will roll they cannot lose to the
Philadelphia Eagles in a bad way let
alone talk about losing at all alright
Michael thanks to the call by the way
just in case you're wondering we picked
up the check we got to check for dinner
[Laughter]
we got another game on a couple Sundays
back in Wembley for the Jags and the
Texans week nine great job great job
this past Sunday was a blast doing it
with you Mike yeah I was fun buddy
absolutely Richard does such a great job
with you do you know man we really it's
a great time being there with the guys
hey I appreciate you but it's the same
same love you too that's Michael Irvin
at Michael Irvin 84 more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app